acting homeland security chief kevin
mchale Enon says separating families at
the border is not on the table in an
interview for this Sunday 60 minutes
according to the Department of Homeland
Security up to 3,000 children may have
been separated from their families
because of president Trump's
now-discontinued zero-tolerance policy
McAlinden told Sharon Alfonzo he regrets
the way the policy was carried out I
think when you lose a public trust in a
law enforcement initiative and you have
to recalibrate at the presidential level
that means that wasn't successful
looking back on it did it work
so the enforcement of the law against
parents who violated our border laws and
brought children with them was effective
it reduced the flow but it didn't work
in the sense that we lost the public
trust it needs to be a follow-up
certainly to that soundbite all right in
our separated and Counting series we are
focusing on families who were broken
apart at the border and are coming
together again last week we brought you
the story of a man who reunited with his
son in Arkansas after nearly a year this
morning Manny Bojorquez brings us
another emotional reunion he introduces
us to two brothers originally from
Honduras who were brought back together
in New York
listen to this after a hundred and
eighty three days apart at Newark
International Airport a nervous and
excited junior or Vetta
stepped off the plane from Houston six
months to the day after being separated
from his eight-year-old brother Andy
when c'mon you know what I mean he's
like a son to you see junior has been
raising Andy on his own for the last
five years the two brothers hoping to
seek asylum arrived at a border crossing
in McAllen Texas on October 17th after a
nearly 1500 mile month-long trip by bus
from a Progreso endued us the next day
Andy was taken from his 21 year old
brother who is not considered his legal
guardian oh my oh my Oriole minore tenia
market our separa
so you're an adult he's a child you
couldn't be in the same place because
you're not technically his father it
took 15 days before junior could finally
speak to his younger brother Andy had
been placed in a foster care center
nearly two thousand miles away in New
York City with other kids his age you
could barely get
through that call Ella style Rondo he
was crying yeah since he was three
you're the only person he's known lonely
couples on that scene last Friday was
the day the brothers had waited 183 days
four so he doesn't know that it's
happening right now - oh yeah no sorry
okay so this might be a bit of a
surprise for him surprise paperwork in
hand Junior walked into the center alone
and minutes later walked out with his
arm tightly wrapped around Andy's
shoulder their oversized smiles marked
the end of their seemingly endless
journey apart
Kenneth jr. but I think he's like your
father they never lost hope they would
see each other again and now that Andy
is back with his big brother this soccer
fanatic had only one thing on his mind
what's the first thing you want to do
what you want to play and play he did
with junior finally at his side for CBS
this morning Manuel Bojorquez New York
we should point out that junior and Andy
are now back in Houston they are waiting
for their court hearing for their Asylum
case the date has not yet been set but I
think is Manning before kisses piece of
point out we discussed policy a lot yeah
we also want to point out the people
behind the policy and how they're
affected it's more than just a number at
Nora's we know that's why I think it's
so good to put a face on those numbers
and what it originally caused such upset
about this was that US policy was
landing on the heads of little children
if that's not something that's happened
before good news is we'll continue to
bring those stories right here on CBS
this morning